sit down
photography is going to
spend extensions
yeah so this is the last talk of a long
Workshop so thanks for for sticking with
me this talk is going to be about
multi-calibration in the covariate shift
setting so similar to two days ago
increased off talk
and it's going to be about when it's
both robust but also in some ways
targeted and optimal
I guess I should say I'm David brunsmith
I'm a computer science PhD student here
and these are my lovely advisors and
collaborators we have Avi who's here
Emmy an economics department and then
two really wonderful collaborators
within Betsy at John Hopkins and Oliver
against who have contributed a lot
okay so I'm going to talk about two
broad approaches to correcting bias that
comes from covaria shift so I'm going to
be thinking about a setting where we
have some training data we're back to XY
pairs from some distribution P but then
in our test distribution queue we Face
some type of covariate shift
and I'm going to focus on the setting
when we're interested in just estimating
the scalar s demand the mean under the
test distribution queue of the outcome Y
and this shows up in all kinds of
problems so I came here from causal
inference this also shows up In fairness
applications when you're looking at sub
populations and it shows up everywhere
in offline reinforcement learning
so the two approaches I'm going to be
comparing are this sort of universal
adaptability Target independent approach
where you fit one predictor in the
training data and if it's
multi-calibrated then you know it works
well for any Target queue so this is a
really nice robustness property
a different approach is if someone tells
you what your cue is beforehand you can
go do some type of targeted estimation
for that particular distribution queue
to get something that's more optimal for
that single Target distribution
and the punch line of the talk is going
to be that there are settings where
there's no gap between these
so we're going to connect the two
approaches with this sort of very simple
algorithm
which is we get some training data with
X Y pairs we fit your favorite ERM
predictor F hat
and then you do one auditing stage where
you do one step of boosting with Ridge
regression to get a multi-accurate
predictor F hat M and then you just plug
that in on your test distribution
and it turns out that this is
numerically identical to a procedure
from causal inference called augmented
balancing weights and this procedure has
all sorts of really nice theoretical
optimality properties for a particular
Target distribution queue
so what do I mean by that oh yeah go
ahead
um you take your f-hat of M and then you
take some X samples from q and just
calculate SM hat xq
I'll be more specific about that in a
bit
okay so the takeaway is that this simple
multi-accurate predictor is not just
robust but no matter which queue you
plug it in subject to certain conditions
it's going to be optimal in all of them
and it's because this this procedure
that this multi-accurate predictor is
numerically identical to turns out to be
semi-parametrically efficient go ahead
um we only after are you using yeah
that'll that'll come up much more
cleanly in a bits that's a great
question
because that was that's kind of what
makes this so weird is that you don't
see q and yet you're simultaneously by
using multi-calibration
semi-parametrically efficient for Q
and this holds in a special setting
where your auditor class belongs to a
Hilbert space so this includes some nice
algorithms like Ridge regression kernel
Ridge regression we're going to show
that it holds for random forests with a
little bit of extra work doesn't hold
for L1 type spaces so lasso is not going
to have the properties that I talk about
okay
lots of related work unfortunately
there's just two both the
multi-calibration literature is big and
they semi-parametric literature is
really big uh so it's hard to review but
the the most directly applicable ones
that I'm interested in are going to be
this Universal adaptability paper which
talks about how multi-calibration can
make you robust to covariate shift and
if you want a primer on all of this like
doubly the title is so funny
semi-parametric doubly robust targeted
double machine learning a review
um gives a nice primer
like pulling together these different
perspectives on the same problem
okay so it'd be a little bit more
precise we're going to assume that we
have some training distribution P we see
some XP and YP draws IID we have a test
distribution q but our yq is missing so
this shows up when you're trying to
estimate an average treatment effect an
observational causal inference where
this would be the treated group our s
demand is going to be the missing mean
under the test distribution
and we're gonna have to make one
assumption which is that the conditional
distribution of Y given X is the same in
the two groups so in causal inference we
call this no unobserved confounding and
biostat is called ignorability in
computer science it's called the
covariate shift assumption but this is
what I mean
okay so one typical procedure would be
just use ERM fit f-hat using p and then
just plug in so this is what I mean by
plug-in estimator where this is
empirical sample average
and the issue is that because you
trained MP and plugged in in Q you can
actually face pretty substantial
selection bias so that this estimator
can be pretty poorly behaved
okay so one idea which shows up in the
multi-calibration literature is that you
try to be robust to many ships you try
to fit an omni predictor across all of
these different dqdps so you assume that
your density ratio dqdp belongs to some
set C that includes you know C1 C2 C3
and then multi-accuracy over this set is
going to ensure some type of small bias
property so here's the definition of
multi-accurate it actually hasn't come
up in the last couple talks so we're
going to refresh
it's when the worst case average
re-weighted residual is small
and in particular
yeah that's right that's right
um to make it multi-calibrated we have
to stick the f-hat in here which for the
purposes of my talk for the numerical
results doesn't make any difference but
in practice if you think about covariate
shift that can adapt to the estimator
that you're using in practice this is a
big difference
but because I'm working with you know
numerical results here
I'm just going to say multi-accurate but
multi-calibrated is fine
so what do we get from multi-accuracy we
get this Universal adaptability property
which is if we're multi-accurate with
respect to this pile of density ratios
then we're approximately unbiased for q1
Q2 and Q3 when we just plug in F hatim
so this is this really nice property and
it has this like sort of well ordering
you only train on P you don't get the CQ
throw it at any q in it it's going to at
least be approximately unbiased
okay so that that suggests this meta
algorithm because one way that we know
of how to get multi-accuracy is by doing
auditing
so if we have our set C of density
ratios we can audit with regression to
get F hat M which is then multi-accurate
and we plug that in on the test sample
and this is the basic meta algorithm of
the universal adaptability paper that
Kristoff alluded to two days ago
okay is everyone with me
all right
we're going to specialize this to a very
theoretically nice function class which
is Hilbert Spaceballs which have lots of
really I mean one of the best things
about them is stuff has numerical closed
forms which is really that's a dream
scenario
but we're going to be thinking about
our points X that belong to a Hilbert
space defined by some inner product
and we're going to be thinking of C as
being a collection of functions defined
as Hilbert space inner products
so what would auditing over Hilbert
Spaceball be its Ridge regression
so I've written it in the familiar
finite dimensional form but you can
think of these as infinite dimensional
matrices and everything's going to go
through fine so this is actually a
pretty big class of algorithms but if at
any point you're grasping for instance
um intuition about what infinite
dimensional regression would mean it
just think about rich regression
okay so this includes Ridge kernel Ridge
actually random forests are just a
special case of Ridge regression but
where the basis is adaptively chosen the
adaptability actually will break our
numerical results but it turns out you
can separately prove that it holds for
random forests which is nice
and it also has been like a sort of
fertile ground for theoretical research
on
neural network generalization with
interpolating estimators which if I get
to the end of the talk we'll we'll talk
about more
okay so I'm gonna say that we are going
to do this
sort of really really simple procedure
we're going to fit f-hat with ERM just
like you would for Universal
adaptability then you're going to fit
Ridge regression on the residuals
so this is boosting it's like it's like
an auditing procedure except it's the
stupidest kind like we just run
regression once
the implied ball C that we're trying to
be multi-accurate with is a Hilbert
Spaceball that's just the meaning of
Ridge regression
and then we're going to form our new
predictor with just this one stage
additive boosting
and we're going to plug that in on Q
I'm going to claim that this thing is
multi-accurate although you'll notice
that this doesn't have the form of
mcboost so I can't use the universal
adaptability paper off the shelf but it
turns out we can still prove that this
simple once boosted Ridge procedure is
multi-accurate and hopefully I'll get to
talk about that at the end but I want to
get through the main results first so
this is somewhat um abnormal there's no
exponential weighting here you're not
running it multiple times until
convergence
okay so before I can actually give you
my main result I need one extra
technical result fortunately it's really
cool and it's just about Ridge
regression
and it's that Ridge regression just
happens to estimate density ratios this
is a really strange fact
one fact that that many people know and
in fact like in my experience learning
theorists love to show everything's a
linear smoother but Ridge regression if
you fit Ridge regression and P and then
just plug it in on xq that's equivalent
to some linear smoother on the yps which
is some function W hat applied to the X
piece
so Ridge regression applied to Q can
always be written as a linear smoother
but W is not just some random function
W solves what in my corner of causal
inference we call balancing weights
between p and Q
which is kind of related to standard
propensity score estimation it's a bit
of a different flavor but basically what
it's doing is least it's an empirical
analog of least squares for the density
ratio
where the key point is that
the function class that we're minimizing
this least squares problem over is is a
Hilbert's baseball
so at least this was very surprising to
me when I learned it that you just fit
Ridge regression plug it in on a target
distribution and really what you're
doing is like implicitly fitting a
density ratio model and then
transferring your outcomes from P to Q
but this equivalence is going to give us
some really nice properties
oh I have a technical Omnibus which is
not about multi-calibration but it's
about this style of result that actually
is going to be announced on archive on
Monday so look out for this paper
augmented balancing weights this linear
regression if you're curious about this
style of result in causal entrance lamp
but
really neat when we apply it to boost it
it basically means that boosting is go
this one this simple one-stage boosting
procedure is going to implement bias
correction
so we have our f-hat M and just as a
reminder F hat m is our original erm
plus this Ridge regression from
Bridge regression on the residuals
that's this right hand term and I just
told you Ridge regression when you plug
it in on Q is the same as an estimator
for the density ratio so we're just
going to plug that in
so we get our base model
and then we get this W hat times the
residuals
and if you well where W hat belongs to
the hilberspace
and if you remember this W hat is a
least squares approximator for dqdp so
this whole term is a bias correction
term you have the error your training
error under P which is y p minus F hat
and you're re-weighting that to look
like what the error should be under q
and that's getting subtracted off
from this biased estimator so you plug
in the biased estimator in this boosting
step on biases it for you
but does this make sense this is the out
this is the sort of algorithmic
numerical equivalence
there's this multi-accurate procedure
that is doing this debiasing for you
automatically
okay so what do we get from that the in
this this meta algorithm where you fit W
hat with something called balancing
weights is called augmented balancing
weights estimators
this thing where you do this boosting
procedure and it turns out to estimate
the density ratio is true for Ridge but
again it's not going to be true for
lasso so this is at least a little bit
of a special case you can't just
regress on the residuals with literally
anything you'd like
okay
fortunately we have this numerical
equivalence to this estimator that
people studied to death so this
estimator has actually been rediscovered
many many times the survey sampler
survey sampling literature calls it
g-reg and it comes from at least 1992.
in causal inference it's been called
augmented Minimax linear estimation
because actually that density ratio
problem can be written in a Minimax form
it's been called approximate residual
balancing that's more my style where I
call it balancing weights and then it
was rediscovered in econometrics where
it's called automatic debiased machine
learning so you might have heard of D
biased machine learning that was the
first generosity puff paper on this and
then he has another one that's called
automatic debias machine learning which
is this estimator
so we have this numerical result Ridge
boosting gives you this augmented
balancing weights and you get this
lovely statistical result which is that
if D if if we have this sort of a
well approximation of the ridge giving
us DQ DP is in h and so we actually are
converging to the truth and if our f-hat
is
a sufficiently good predictor to begin
with it can't just be junk
you get semi-parametric efficiency so
here's just two examples of proofs of
this type of thing in Hilbert spaces
um what does semi-parametric efficiency
mean it means that we're optimal in the
sense of achieving some type of variance
lower bound
if you don't like asymptotics there's
also nice non-esympotic results like
this paper from Berkeley for example
so if you don't like asymptotics you can
believe me that this is still a good
type of result to get
this is one thing that I feel like is a
little bit underappreciated amongst
computer scientists but you'll get an
asymptotic normal confidence interval
which is really nice it means you do
your plug-in estimator and you just get
the easiest just calculate your standard
errors and you get
a nice uncertainty quantification
estimate and in particular ERM plugins
will not give you a valid asymptotic
confidence interval so this is just a
nice this is the bonus and again it's
not a bonus if you don't don't like
asymptotics but something that you can
compute to put in a paper with with
standard errors
and also more agnostically we don't
necessarily need dqdp to be correctly
specified in the Hilbert space as long
as we get like things are non-parametric
enough and we can estimate things that
are sufficiently good rate you're still
going to get efficiency and that's
discussed at length in this paper
orthogonal statistical learning which
maybe is more familiar to this audience
I'm not sure
doesn't look like it but yes finite
sample everything so so that could be
nice
all right so let's summarize what do we
show we show that you fit this W hat
this F hat M which I claim is
multi-accurate it's a simple auditing
procedure
if you plug it in on q1
it's equivalent to estimating dq1 DP and
using it for bias correction
but the same thing is true if you plug
it in on Q2
and the same thing is true if you plug
it in on Q3
and so this is very strange because F
hat M never got to see any data from Q
there's only using data from P but it
somehow optimally implements transfer
learning
to any cue
such that dqdp is in this Hilbert's
baseball
so that's the big picture summary
I'm going to have a quick discussion and
because I still have 10 minutes I'm
going to subject you all to the
technical results but I prom it has
colors they're both equations and colors
so I promise it won't be that bad but a
quick discussion before I do that
I intentionally didn't fill up the time
so that I could give you the proofs
anyway
there's no cost of robustness for
covariate shift at least
in this sort of Hilbert space type
setting
this works for other linear smoothers as
well so Random forests technically are
not literally Ridge regression because
of this adaptivity of the basis but
there is this really lovely paper that
proved that the weights for the linear
smoother version of random forests also
converge at a pretty fast rate to dqdp
under conditions
there are some interesting algorithmic
questions here because when I say A
Hilbert's baseball I'm usually
envisioning an infinite dimensional
Hilbert space some type of like flexible
Power full regression which is more in
this like strong learning type
uh approach and not really in the spirit
of boosting which was more looking at
like taking these weak Learners and
building them up on each other and so
there's some interesting algorithmic
questions about
connecting multi-accuracy and this type
of result outside of this narrow
estimator that I'm proposing
it also works for other estimates so
I've just been talking about the missing
mean but actually this is more in the
spirit of the talk we saw about which
statistics can be multi-calibrate which
statistics can we run this estimator on
and still get the same result well it's
any mean squared continuous linear
functional of the conditional
expectation
so that
is a little bit complicated sounding but
it means that if you want to estimate
something like an average derivative
this multi-accurate predictor type
approach is going to give you the exact
same efficiency results
it will also work you can just plug this
into Kristoff's talk from two days ago
because he uses the exact same setup and
you actually get instead of the
t-learner you get a variation called the
Dr learner which is proposed by Kennedy
just as a numeric
immediate result from from his proposed
estimator which is also an interesting
connection I won't have that much to say
about that because when you're when
you're estimating something uniformly
all the math gets more complicated means
are so nice very simple
okay and behind the scenes is a story
about overfitting which I'm going to
talk to you about in the next five
minutes does anyone have any questions
about
the rest of the talk
team which gives you
yes
so
this is the type of like likelihood
ratio estimation problem I'm claiming
Ridge implements
um
it's equivalent to this simple
minimization problem and it turns out
that the solution to this minimization
problem so you know how Ridge is going
to be like it's basically going to look
like X transpose X inverse X transpose y
with your Ridge penalty in there
and then when you apply that to xq you
slap an xq on it
the solution to this problem is xq X
transpose X inverse X transpose
so if you slap a y on it it's equal to
Rich
so that's that's the numerical
the fact that this is equivalent to this
is now so hard to see you just have to
plug in the trick is that you apply
reach representation through
and does
teacher work well
that's a problem
so you can't get efficiency without
overlap because you can't correct the
bias but I'm pretty sure that this is
the right thing to do if you have
overlap violations because you're not
inverting a propensity score
hey we had a cause Olympics question
studies
okay yes I mean that is that is really
what it comes down to so
okay
I still have five minutes so hold on to
that that that's that's really important
so why does this whole multi-accuracy
hold even though we're doing this much
simpler
boosting procedure
so this is the definition this is like
the left-hand side of multi
app where you recall that this is Ridge
regression on the residuals
if you just use so this is
multi-accuracy over Hilbert's baseball
this thing is exactly equal to this
expression
which is the gradient of the squared
loss
of the residual regression problem
measured in the Hilbert space alarm
so this is just using the Dual Norm
trick right you have some
a soup over a ball you should be
envisioning that there's a dual Norm
somewhere that you can swap and what's
the Dual Norm in Hilbert space it's
Hilbert space Norm so everything has
this nice nice form
okay but but solving least squares lost
minimization precisely makes this thing
small
and so what I have this type of
inequality that I can show for example
which is that when you do the boosting
you have the gradient of the loss of the
original estimator and then you're
always going to shrink it
so this is a little bit informal because
actually we can just do better by
analyzing this thing directly this is
kind of like a cute inequality but I
think the cute inequality helps you get
a better intuition for what's going on
we're always overfitting
we're making the gradient of the loss
smaller that means closer to the best
fit that we can get
so if multi-accuracy is in this Hilbert
space setting is how aggressively we fit
the squared loss we have this story of
overfitting especially if you fit this
with erm
and when you do boosting you're always
going to get something that's fit like
at least as aggressively
and it turns out that this is the right
thing to do for
um Hilbert space regression that there's
all this this
um barrage of result results that show
if you do rkhs kernel Ridge regression
and then want to apply it under
covariate shift it's optimal to choose a
Lambda that's smaller than the one you
would choose from cross-validation
so at least to me that was sort of
obvious for when you're estimating an
average because average is
wash out variants and so you want to
choose a Lambda that's smaller but the
surprising result is that even if you
care about predictive mean squared error
under covariate shift you should still
use a smaller Lambda
um when you're doing an rkhs type
regression so there's this weird
connection where if you want to be
robust to covaria shift in Hilbert
spaces you should regularize less
and that's a little bit in tension with
empirical work which usually shows that
when you have covariate shift you want
to regularize more to be robust to it
so I don't have necessarily a solution
to why this is the case but one extreme
case of this is interpolation
so ridgeless boosting on the residuals
will make this exactly zero
AKA you're doing ordinary least squares
in infinite dimensions
and so that's exactly what this quite
popular benign overfitting paper studies
and there's been many other situations
where people have been setting this
gradient the squared loss to exactly
zero and then studying the resulting
estimator
so
I've kind of snuck in knowledge about Q
in my procedure
because
you fit this with erm
really to get a totally optimal
estimator for a particular Target queue
you might need to change the Lambda of
how much you overfit and it's going to
depend on the size of the covariate
shift but for all of the distributions
with the same size of covariate shift
like you can think of that as a shell
you should use the same plugin estimator
okay and we're at uh
basically the end so if anyone has any
questions
all right people want uh
speakers and all the participants it's
great to see so many of users